um
yeah
let's
do it
wait what happened to my music see this
is what i'm talking about y'all this is
like it was just working
oh my god
[Laughter]
well welcome to live freaking
you know that's what happens when you do
stuff live
you know i just tested it everything was
working great and then all of a sudden
all of a sudden now it's not working
like what
you know what i mean
like none of this makes sense man
none of them
like what is going on here
okay
i got that plugged
in we're gonna make it work i mean i
just tested it you know
what
i just oh my god dude
what
well welcome to riffing with griffin
y'all
appreciate y'all being here
you know it is what it is
you know it's always something
there's always something here at
riffenwood griffin studios
hello
well we got the singing mic is working
you know what i mean
singing mic is working let's see we got
the music
music is not working i don't understand
what happened
i mean it literally was just working
just fine
so
i don't know
really
just really utterly annoying but anyways
welcome to riffing with griffin how you
all doing
we doing it live i like doing it live
because it's easier for me to do it live
especially if i don't have a guest
and then you know it challenges me to
like you know be on point with my takes
and the things that i want to talk about
and you know and here we are you know
what i'm saying
yeah it just it won't it won't work and
i don't know why it won't work
i don't know why it's not working y'all
like like super frustrating
especially because it was just working
like
it literally was just working
you know i don't i don't
i don't understand
why it's not working
and this is why you need like
i guess this is why you need like
producers and stuff like that you know
what we're just gonna do it like this
[Laughter]
we just gonna do it like that
[Music]
[Music]
okay that's good enough
i'm so sorry i don't know what happened
i i literally do not know what happened
i don't know how to make it work you
know like i have this cord right here
like this cord
you know
it hooks up to my
tc whatever
a thon thing
and it usually
you know it usually works
it was just working i don't i don't know
why it stopped working you know
i have no idea why i stopped working
like it literally doesn't make any sense
to me but you know it is what it is
so
oh well this is what happens when you do
a live podcast
anything can happen
i just unplugged it
i unplugged it i plugged it back in
you know what i mean i mean the mic
works which is crazy
[Music]
you know that works but you know i don't
know what and then like um
i'm getting that
you know i get the the sound i plug it
in and
it just doesn't work like it's not going
through you know and i don't know why
it's doing that
you know so who knows maybe i'll restart
my phone so i can get that and when i do
the end it'll work but anyways welcome
to griffin with griffin y'all
um
man what a week you know
last week
with all the drama
all the drama with everything was going
on in the podcast world
i don't know i let it affect me more
than it should have
i did a patreon episode and by the way
thanks for subscribing thanks for being
here thanks for subscribing to riffin
with griffin so please
hit the subscribe hit the share button
and all that stuff hit the notifications
so you know when i'm going live and all
that so i appreciate you and also you
know i'm on twitch a lot so you know i'm
a twitcher
daddy is a gamer so make sure you check
me out on that i game
so on twitch eric griffin gaming so
check me out there appreciate that
and if you are interested uh i do
episode i'm doing some extra content on
the patreon so if you want to join the
patreon the links down below it's just
eric patreon you know eric griffin so i
do stuff there and how i do that is i go
live on twitch subscriber only so if
you're a subscriber on my twitch you're
gonna get that content if you're a
patreon member you're going to get that
content or if you're a youtube member
you also will get that content so like
if you're a youtube member if you want
to do that sign up you know youtube you
can uh you can be on there too
and i will um
you'll get that content also that extra
content so i appreciate you you want to
support me support the show i'm i'm
enjoying doing this
shout out to my new producer chris
kristen espinoza
she is helping me with like a lot of my
social media content putting putting
this stuff out getting the podcast out
i'm gonna restructure how i'm gonna do
this
eventually have guests and but i'm
streamlining this more other than this
stupid like like again when these kind
of things happen i don't know why it
happens i literally don't know why that
happened like literally the music was
just i tested it and then i went live
and this moment i went live it didn't
work but anyways welcome back so last
week
last week there was a bunch of drama as
you know
i won't go into it i actually didn't
want to talk about it but i actually
talked i was talking to my therapist
um and it was just like it was more
about me you know i was talking about my
therapist for me about like what what i
like to do what i like to talk about and
my own issues you know and i do
recommend therapy because when you start
you go to therapy you start talking to
you really start to like
this person
understands patterns and behavior and
and you think that you're okay you think
you oh no i'm fine and then you start to
realize oh man that actually is an issue
and you can start to recognize it so i
recognized something with this when when
it came to that drama with the
podcasters and the podcast drama i
started to see like how why was it
affecting me and i started to ask myself
i wonder why it was affecting me and i
talked to my therapist about it because
it really was bugging me and what it is
what was bugging me is like
this silent this loud minority of people
who were like sort of attacking me like
hey support your friends support your
friend like bringing me into this like
as if i owed them an explanation and and
why did that affect me and it just goes
to like um
being a people pleaser you know
like uh
so then you start to ask yourself like
am i am i trying to please these people
or you know is like or then you start to
go like why like why am i in the middle
am i in the middle of certain things
because i don't want to ruffle any
feathers or am i in the middle and
that's just
what it is or or or am i in the middle
because i don't want to take a stand or
you know what i mean you start to you so
you start to question so i had to ask
myself that and it was like no when i
look back on it i'm not necessarily in
the middle i just have an opinion about
how i feel both sides are handled the
situation and i have my own opinion
about what i like and don't like and i
can support both of my friends without
and feel good about it and so i'm fine
i'm good i'm good with where i am with
it i think the whole thing is being
handled terribly um this just the kind
of stuff all this business shouldn't be
out like this and you know that's how i
feel about it so um uh i think it's
unfair to everybody and
you know i have i'm i'm okay with where
i am with it and i actually i'm it's a
zero f's i care i care about it now now
i realize like it doesn't matter so like
the people that are still attacking me
and stuff like that now i'm just kind of
like brush it off your shoulders because
now i'm at a place where i'm like okay i
know how i feel and i'm okay with how i
feel and i don't care what anybody
thinks about where i'm at because it
does it doesn't really matter people are
going to have their own opinion so it is
what it is and i don't know i don't owe
anyone
but myself
and the people that i care about those
are the only people that really matters
how i think so you know it was something
to think about you know it really was
something to think about and be like ooh
you know it's like
because then i started to think about my
comedy i started to think like um
i don't necessarily have a middle of the
road with my comedy i take like strong
stands in my comedy so that made me i
looked at that and i was like okay good
because i don't wanna i wanna make sure
that i'm putting my point out and
sometimes i ruffle feathers with people
they don't agree with what i say and so
if you don't you know not everyone's
gonna agree with you so you have to be
okay with that you know that's the thing
about doing comedy like you know you're
gonna say something and there's gonna be
people who are gonna be like oh
you're wrong and
unfortunately
it's always the loud minority of people
it's always the ones that uh
have some like visceral reaction but
they you know they a lot of times they
misunderstand you or they take their own
approach and then they attack you it's
always the negative people that attack
you the positive people just watch the
positive people just go they agree in
silence
uh and you have to remember that and uh
and i do appreciate when
those type of people actually go out of
their way to go hey man i see you
getting a lot of negativity i just want
you to know i appreciate you and blah
blah blah so thank you for those people
that reach out but uh you know but i'm
just working on my own thing so it was
good to
you know it was good to like talk it out
with my therapist just to make sure
make sure i was like you know above
board with my thoughts make sure that i
wasn't
was i being too affected by this like
small drama from people that were just
hitting it just i realized it was just
an annoyance
you know people annoy you on the
internet because they go go go and it's
just like but actually you know i got
rid of a lot of that because like like i
said last week if you send me a message
that i feel is just out of bounds out of
pocket rude dis distasteful
disrespectful
you know i on instagram it goes restrict
remove follower hide story and then any
and then when your message comes up it
comes up like restrict if i see the word
restrict i just delete and i'll never i
never see it i'll never see it again
so
and there are some people who i'm sure
that maybe they thought they were being
funny or whatever it is like that i just
i'm never going to see your messages
again on twitter i just mute them so
they can still talk and talk and talk
but i'll never see it so that's just how
i handle that i'm not a blocker i don't
think it's blocking people they give
give them too much power you know you
block somebody then they're like oh you
blocked me and then they they they
always screen cap that you know what i
mean then they put it up like look who
blocked me and you know as if they you
know
i don't know maybe it's a lot of energy
expended but i just like i like what i
like when everybody wins you know when
somebody is restricted they still think
they can send you messages so they're
getting all that energy out i just never
see it but they feel good about it for
themselves that they did something you
know i told him off so they win the
people on twitter you know they're muted
so i never see it but they it's out
there for them so they win and then i
win because i don't care and i don't i
don't i don't have to see it so
it is what it is so
and then you know people always say that
just stay off twitter i like social
media
i like being on social media i like
interacting i like tweeting things i
like seeing things and so it is what it
is i don't know what else to do in terms
of that so you know i'm not gonna not do
that so that's just uh you know where it
is with that you know
so let's see if let's see if the music
worked i i restarted my phone i think
that might that might have been the
thing so i just i just you know i just
want to check it out and see if it still
doesn't work then i know i have to do
something else
there it is y'all
late intro
[Music]
thank you for watching
your favorite podcast
[Music]
okay we got it in
uh i just like doing that you know it's
not a podcast unless i get to sing it in
right
okay so today we are got a lot to talk
about
so let's
start it off with
the nba
playoffs y'all let's start off with the
nba playoffs
um
wow i haven't talked about the nba in a
little while uh i got a poll up right
now who you think is going to win the
championship so let me know for all you
nba fans
uh final four you know we got miami
boston
we got golden state and dallas and they
all have incredible stories and so
whoever wins is going to have a
tremendous story and even individual
accomplishments i think is great
so let's just go down the line here so
you know first up
uh miami versus boston so miami was the
number one seed and i don't think
they're getting a lot of respect for
that i think that people
are just kind of letting it go by the
wayside they don't have a lot of flashy
names on their team the main guy they
have is jimmy butler and i don't think i
don't think people look at jimmy butler
as like he's not a flashy star you know
jimmy butler's not but even though he's
in a bunch of commercials and he's like
you know he's out there there's just
something about jimmy butler that
doesn't it's not like steph curry lebron
james or even jason tatum is something
it's something that's like like like
like like right below that in terms of
his persona that he's not projecting
that superstar
superstar thing even though you know in
the bubble he was in the championship
and he was going shot for shot with
lebron he had a couple of 40-point games
you know he was trying his best to as
the fifth seed to win the championship
so they have a lot to prove they're
trying to prove that that wasn't a fluke
we deserved to be in the championship
and here we are yeah he's got no sizzle
for the people in the chat somebody said
that and i totally agree
jimmy butler is lacking the sizzle but
it doesn't mean he's lacking the game so
jimmy butler is a monster you know what
i mean he's averaging 28 seven and five
in the playoffs right now so he he is
ready he is raring to go so
um i think that miami has a good story
again they want to prove that they
deserve to be in the championship they
want to prove that they are great and
they are a great franchise if you think
about it they you know when they had
when they had dwyane wade and shaq they
went to the championship they had lebron
dwyane wade chris boss they went to the
championship now and then they went to
the championship again with jimmy butler
and here they are again so miami's one
of those storied franchises that goes to
the championship whether we like it or
not it is what it is so congratulations
to miami for making it that far
so that's the story but to me that's the
number four story in the playoffs that
wouldn't that would be the least
exciting story for me if miami won it
would just be like okay
good for the people of miami i'm not
excited about it i'm more excited about
boston i'm actually picking boston to
win this series
i like what boston is doing boston
unfortunately ran into lebron james for
a couple of years while jayson tatum was
in his early 20s but they got to the
eastern conference finals three times
and they just went up against a better
opponent right
they went up against a superstar so here
they are again so let's look what they
did first round they go up against the
nets who was favored to beat them they
sweep them
uh jason tandem shows himself to be a
superstar right going to the next round
against the defending champs the
milwaukee bucks that that goes seven
jason tatum has like a couple of games
where
um it didn't go his way but if you look
at the stats when he scores over 25 they
win so it it all goes on jayson tatum
jason tatum plays well they won against
the bucks and they did giannis had a
game where he had like 44 and 20 40 and
20. 40 points 20 rebounds jason tatum
had 46 points and they won that game
they eventually won that series i think
chris middleton not being with the bucks
was a huge
huge letdown for the bucks they needed
that extra star they just didn't have
enough to go up against the best defense
in the league in the second half of the
league
of the of the
the season
the celtics had the best record and they
had the best um what do you call it they
had the best defense going into the
second half of the season and in the
playoffs they play really great defense
they are a great team they play team
defense and they have a superstar and
then they have another guy who has
superstar talent in uh and brown and
they just have a bunch of great role
players and scorers so i think they're
just a really complete team and
i think it's going to be a great series
it's probably going to go seven but i do
think that
the boston celtics are the better team i
well i i'm pulling for them and that's
just a great story this is the what's on
the line right now is jason tatum as a
top five player in the nba jason tatum
is like hey consider me the best player
in the league that's what he's going for
right now he's got that kind of talent
he got that kind of game he's 24 years
old
you know he got 40 point game ability at
any particular time
and i think he's going to showcase that
in this to go to the championship so
they got a lot to prove i think it's a
great score story they got a new coach
they got a new coach homeboy i forgot
his name but you know another
african-american coach uh first year
coach doing the damn thing
people bought into his system of playing
defense playing as a team and letting
the stars be stars and facilitate as
well as playing defense they shut kevin
durant down you understand what i'm
saying like one of the greatest players
of all time looked did not look good in
that first round shut him down so that's
the kind of defense that they're playing
and a lot of times jason tatum was on
him and they did the same thing so i'm
curious to see if the celtics are gonna
do the same thing to the heat like are
they gonna decide we're gonna shut
we're gonna shut butler down and we're
gonna let tyler hero and these other
guys do what they do i have a feeling
that that's how they're gonna do it so
we'll see how that goes but it's gonna
be a fantastic series i think the game's
on right now actually so
uh look out for that series and i'll be
talking about the playoffs moving
forward okay in the other side we got
the dallas mavericks and the golden
state warriors
now dallas mavericks
they found another euro sensation you
know this euro trash uh
i say that lovingly though i don't mean
i don't mean it in a bad way i just like
always calling european players euro
trash especially when i'm at the game
would you stop this euro trash
but luca is the truth man the dude is
for real he just don't look like it he
looks slow and lumbering but man in
these four games he's averaging like
he's averaging a playoff like 35 37 38
points again it's something crazy like
that where he's in a he's in line with
jordan and lebron james for the most
points scored in the playoffs especially
especially in closeout games the dude is
a monster he's carrying dallas
and for him and he's also the youngest
player to be doing it like this he's
only 23 years old i believe
and he's about to on the verge of going
to the championship putting himself like
just to put it in context jordan and
lebron were 27 years old when they first
got their team to the championship so
luca is baldwin
and jason kidd as a first year coach
with them has changed the culture there
showing himself to be an excellent coach
kudos to him probably should really be
coach of the year in retrospect when you
look at everything but you know it is
what it is especially because monty
williams got just demolished the sun so
sons just looked so terrible dallas just
took them out it was crazy um
but kudos to dallas that would be a
pretty good story if dallas wins the
championship i just think dallas is a
boring franchise so it's not what i
would want to see but i totally get if
they win the championship it would be
like wow that would be great luca would
vault himself up to being like the best
player in the league it would be like
you would have to look at him like that
giannis
dude luca lebron kd you would jason you
would have to look at him like that
because of what what he is doing so
kudos to that story now to me the best
story in the playoffs the best
it would be the golden state warriors
winning the winning the championship now
i am a golden state warriors hater
because i'm a clippers fan i love the
clippers and i hated that we couldn't
get past golden state in the in the um
in the what it was in the lob city era
we couldn't we just couldn't get past
him it was always injuries chris paul
getting hurt blake griffin getting hurt
we couldn't get past those
and so you know
and then doc rivers choking it away with
his you know 3-1 losing self
you know what i mean so
i'm a golden state hater but i will say
this
i am pulling for golden state
because i like the story
so
year one of golden state winning the
championship not only did every starting
point guard in the western conference
was injured they make it to the
championship kyrie irving and kevin love
get injured right
they win in six
we all there isn't a person alive who
thinks that the cleveland cavaliers
would not have beaten the [ __ ] out of
them with kevin love and kyrie irving
playing in that championship okay
no one thinks that they would have won
that all right even golden state fans
you fooling yourself you lying to
yourself if you think that the cleveland
wouldn't have beat them and it would
have changed all of history right so it
is what it is lebron james does the best
he can he carries them six games but
they lose to golden state steph curry
their supposed best player doesn't even
win the mvp of the play of the finals it
goes to iguodala which was weird to me
right so it is what it is okay then the
next year they come back they win 73
games they have the best record ever in
the regular season but they lose to
lebron james they lose three they they
were up 3-1 and they lose
okay so that was like a mark on them
even though they think that hey we would
have won if draymond green hadn't been
um hadn't been ejected but he was
ejected stop getting technical files
fool that's on you he had the most
technical files up to that point if he
had he had 15 technical files
at 16 technical files you get it you get
suspended for a game he was at 15 16 he
got suspended that's on him
shut your mouth maybe right so he he
cost them that championship with his
mouth and his actions okay so it is what
it is
so they lose right which
then the next year they go they get
kevin durant which was like ridiculous
so nobody like it was just like no
competition we you know lebron james did
the best he could and it just it is what
it is the golden state warriors win
those two championships but zero people
outside of golden state respect it
no one respects those championships
zero people respect them okay so now
you have
kevin durant decides well i'm leaving
i'm gonna go do it someplace else
because he was getting so much hate and
then whatever happened with you know
he's a runner you know
he didn't want to work it out with
russell westbrook so he left he didn't
want to work it out with golden state so
he left now here he is with the nets and
he gets waxed
they they can't put it together
they can't put it together somebody's
injured he can't he can't carry the team
then they get into the playoffs he's got
kyrie
penn simmons not playing
james harden runs away and then they get
waxed by boston 4-0 so now you're
looking at it like well is kevin durant
the greatest player of all time maybe
maybe not so this is what i'm saying
about golden state's story what i like
about it is this golden state is trying
to show hey
we are for real champs
it wasn't just because of kevin durant
that we won the championship we are
champions our system brings the best out
of people and we're going to approve it
by winning the championship this year if
golden state wins the championship this
year it elevates all those players it
elevates golden state and it actually to
me legitimizes those two led
championships with kevin durant because
one
look what jordan poole is doing
there they got a g-league player looking
like an all-star so that system
makes people look better than they are
now kevin durant is a great player but
now we've seen him by himself
he
he was having some choke job games in
oklahoma city against golden state when
they lost they were up 3-1 against miami
in a championship right and then now
look against boston and you know what i
mean and then even against uh even
against the bucks last year there was a
couple games where he just didn't have
it so maybe he's not the greatest player
that we thought he was and maybe he
needed golden state to really shine and
the golden state's gonna prove that if
they win the championship it will
legitimize their whole legacy and and
stephen curry needs to be he needs to be
the mvp of the finals
and that will even legitimize his career
as being one of the greatest players of
all time already the greatest shooter of
all time i like that golden state story
i like it
i like the drama of it i like it a lot i
want to see that happen i want to see
them because you know they're trying to
do this they're trying to do this for
themselves too because even they
want to prove to kevin durant and the
rest of the league nah man
we're champ we made you a champion you
didn't make us a champion we made you a
champion that's what they're trying to
prove right now because we could see
like i said kevin durant ain't making
nobody a champion man
he's
like he may never win a championship
again in his career and we're going to
look back on this and if they win this
will legitimize that i would like to see
golden state boston in the championship
and then whoever wins i'll be happy i
love both those stories
there we go i did it
that's my nba talk for this week
nba talk
all right now we're going into
some spoilers
some thoughts
i want to go into
um
i saw
dr strange
i saw the doctor strange man and i want
to talk about it i tweeted about it
put it on instagram
rest in peace mcu
marvel cinematic universe
rest in police rest in peace what do i
mean by that
okay
not a fan of this movie i did not like
it now let me put it in context okay so
you're talking about 13 years of
maybe like 75 hit rate of movies leading
up to avengers endgame
you know i i wasn't a fan of all the
movies in in that that went through this
process you know i thought the first
captain america was a
it was just okay
uh you know i thought iron man 3
terrible i thought thor 2 dark world
could have done without it
um
there was just there was just some
movies along the way leading to endgame
that were just like so so so enjoyable
maybe saw him once i was okay with it
even some of the avengers movies like
avengers age of ultron could have done
without it
but
you know what it led up to this
spectacular ending the whole thing had a
purpose the mcu had a purpose it was
defeating thanos
all the stories were connected our minds
were like this is great i love all this
we were invested in every character we
knew even the smallest characters we
knew it branched off into other movies
we just it was just great like the whole
thing was great i'm glad i lived through
it it was a spectacular time in movie
making for superhero movies and it was
fantastic thumbs up big woo-woos for the
cinematic universe the marvel cinematic
universe
but after that it is now dead
i'm sorry it does not have the same
luster they tried we got the shanxi
movie where they they incorporated the
the doctor strange guy you know the
asian guy came into that movie and they
tried to imply that oh something big is
coming right
not invested okay and shang ji was like
it was okay all right it was okay okay
then you have eternals the the you know
the woke eternals with the woke casting
which but but you know what though i've
actually watched eternals like seven or
eight times because it's on disney plus
and you know it's an enjoyable movie
like i could keep watching it i like the
characters i like the story but is it
connected to the mcu it seems like it's
its own universe now they connected
blade even though they didn't show him
but blade is in the eternals in the end
you hear his voice in the end credit
thing so is that some sort of connection
but it's not the same it seems
disjointed it doesn't seem really
connected and i liked it when that all
this stuff was connected leading to a
purpose that's why the mcu is dead now
cut to dr strange now in the first
doctor strange at the end of doctor
strange in the um post credits they had
that one guy
where is it what's his name um
let me go to my doctor strange uh
imdb page
oh let me get it up here dr strange
doctors
doctor strange
doctor strange where is it two thousand
here yes okay so
yes when you look at the cast of doctor
strange uh god what was that guy's name
oh yeah i can't i can never say his name
oh you know what let me go to that for
the people that are watching
for all you people that are that aren't
you know watching the uh if you're
listening his name is
this guy
chiwetly i don't know how to say his
name
[Laughter]
but he played mordo you know anyway in
the first movie if you were this guy
chuetel chuettel how do you say his name
chowettle
what a weird name you know how can you
be a star with that name but that guy's
in a lot of stuff he's a great actor i
love this guy but in the original doctor
strange if you remember you know at the
end credit they were showing him he's
now anti-magic and he's like oh we gotta
get get rid of uh magic in the universe
okay
um
you know what i mean uh um
and then and that's what he was doing
you know what i mean and so then but
they never
they never
that that storyline never went you know
went to fruition they never really they
never really dealt with that you know
they never really went for it you know
what i mean
uh let me do another poll is the is the
mcu dead yes or no
and so
so now
they just but doctor strange was so
great with iron man you know cumberbatch
and uh what's his face they had such a
great chemistry that they kind of like
forgot that storyline and they went into
this so then the spider-man cartoon the
multiverse spider-man cartoon
really like that storyline of multiverse
was like so popular that the mcu people
were like you know what we got to take
this on so then they did the spider-man
um
you know what i mean they did they did
the spider-man
uh
uh multiverse movie that just came out
no way home and it was spectacular it
was fantastic but that wasn't really an
mcu movie even though doctor strange was
in it and they found a way to actually
remove peter parker
uh you know from the mcu if they wanted
to and i think that's what they're gonna
do i think it's back to sony and they're
gonna make their own thing but like you
know it was sort of connected but not
but that was a great stand-alone movie
that spider-man movie right so what's up
with doctor strange so then they're
hyping up this new doctor strange movie
so here we are so this is what i'm
saying i say all that to say that this
doctor strange movie
it's it's not really connected to
anything you know if you've watched a tv
series so they had the scarlet witch doc
tv series which i thought was wanda
vision and wanda which was so great it
was such so good so they sort of make
reference to that but my problem was
this wasn't a great movie it wasn't
great storytelling it was like still all
over the place and they also picked up
in the story like to me an hour in
because you didn't really know
why i like spoiler alert like i said
this is spoilers why is wanda the bad
guy you know like it's not and they
didn't really explain it enough like if
you saw the wanda series maybe you kind
of understand but to me in this movie it
couldn't be a standalone movie they
didn't explain it enough and it was it
just wasn't enough i didn't believe it
and so you got wanda being the bad guy
and then you got like this multi-verse
traveler
and then like it's just a story that i
was like what is this connected to
what does this have to do with the
eternals what does this have to do with
shang ji what does this have to do with
like like you know what are you doing to
keep it all together there was no
purpose
no like it was so disjointed and i i
didn't think it was a good standalone
movie now now was it an enjoyable movie
by itself
maybe
great action cumberbatch is a great
actor but like to me i'm so invested in
the mcu universe to see where it's going
next that i thought they were still
gonna do that and they let us know that
they're not
they're not doing that
it doesn't seem and then they just like
have this like
this like end scene
where you're like okay
who's that character like what does that
have to do with anything
maybe they're going to bring it all
together in the like if they do an
eternals 2 which i think they are
maybe they'll bring all this together
with the blade movie with the um uh the
one the dude from game of thrones the
guy that was in eternals i think they're
doing something with him maybe a tv
series but like i don't know at this
point i like the tv series the the the
stuff they're doing on disney plus
marvel i like that more than i like this
standalone movie i thought moon night
was a really great series i enjoyed um i
enjoyed loki loki is great how about
this
we're the time cops man
where's where's those things you know
and then they did this thing in they did
this thing in uh
in this doctor strange where they're
trying to do more multiverse stuff where
here's the x-men and here's fantastic
four
i didn't like none of them okay patrick
stewart seemed old he seemed checked out
he didn't really seem like he wanted to
be charles xavier anymore i think after
the wolverine movie he was done but they
probably said hey man we'll give you
millions of dollars you want to do this
and he was like okay
he didn't seem invested i don't like jim
from uh i don't like jim from the office
being fantastic four guy
and like you know it's just i didn't
like it it didn't make me excited for a
fantastic four movie it didn't make me
excited for like bringing the x-men in
and just i didn't like it i just i i
didn't like it y'all uh it was like i
said a lot of action thrilling but it
was disjointed and not connected and i
just didn't like it
you know and i'm disappointed and that's
why i think the mcu is dead the mcu as
we know it is dead because it's too
disjointed it's not connected there's no
through line story it's just kind of
like
standalone movies you know and maybe
next time i'll discuss like who do we
think who do we think is going to win
moving forward dc or marvel
did you like batman or did you like
um
doctor strange you know stand-alone
movies because now we know that
like in the dc universe the flash movies
coming out and i heard that ben affleck
is going to reprise his role as batman
in that movie
so that stuff's still going on so
they're going to have wonder woman
aquaman they still trying to connect
sort of over there and i like those i
think aquaman was a great movie i
thought aquaman was a fine standalone
movie i thought the first wonder woman
was pretty good second one but that
dude's a great actor
we'll see if this flash movie is going
to be good and then i thought that
um but everything else was just kind of
like whatever justice league they
dropped the ball so you know who's going
to win moving forward you know i don't
know but for a long time marvel universe
was in the lead marvel was on top and
now after you know uh then they're gonna
do a second batman and hope this joker's
gonna come in he had the riddler i mean
it was dark it was you know it was too
long and overall was an enjoyable movie
but i don't know man i don't know we'll
see i think marvel right now at the top
is the marvel tv series i think the tv
portion of marvel is winning you know i
like that i like low-key i liked i liked
uh i liked uh blackhawk is that how you
say it hawkeye hawkeye blackhawk i liked
hawkeye i thought that was a great
series i enjoyed as a standalone movie
black widow i thought that female
superhero
from a female perspective and how they
made it i thought they did a great job
with that and i like that character
what's her face in that movie
who plays black uh black widow's sister
she was great in the hawkeye series and
i hope they bring her into the universe
i wish that you know what i'm saying
like
they i i don't know why i don't know
what they're doing yet so i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna have judgment but as of
right now i feel like it's dead
i'm looking at the poll right now i put
up a poll is the mcu dead and right now
it's 55 say no 45 say yes with 94 votes
so you know only some of you agree with
me
um
like i say man this is just just looking
at doctor strange
this movie to me could have been a
bridge to
you know bringing these other movies
that have already come out into like
show us where this is going
because they imply that they're
connected like i said
the dude from doctor strange
that plays um
what's that character um
the the who what like who's the asian
guy what does he play
he plays
um
wong yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that guy
he was in shanghai
implying that the dr strange universe is
connected to that
what happened to that you know what i
mean like what happened
i just i think they dropped the ball
that's what uh
that's what i feel and i see in the chat
too
it just was missing something
doctor strange two was missing something
i can't put my finger on it but i know
it was missing something so hopefully
with movies that are coming out
they'll bring it back together and we'll
see
what
happens but that's how i feel
about that all right
all right next up big spoiler so if you
don't want to watch you know
if you don't want to hear about it then
this is your time to leave
but
let's talk about the end of ozarks
ozarks uh that's where we're at now and
if you want to leave thanks you for
watching we're from with griffin but
there's been enough time i'm not gonna
you know hold back
uh
ozarks
you know four seasons um this was
overall this was a really great series
jason bateman did a great job as the
creator and and director in some of the
episodes an actor
um i loved these characters
these characters were just so
complicated and just like uh they're
just not good you know they weren't they
weren't good people and even though they
were trying to be good people you know i
just
um
[Music]
it just
i it
it was great i thought season one was
really good i thought season two was it
was
okay
season three i wasn't a huge fan of but
season four i thought they ended it
great um
you know so if you don't know what
ozarks is about it's about this guy who
he's a he's a money launderer
and his partner
uh was caught stealing from the mexican
cartel
and then they were going to kill him and
then at the same time his wife is
cheating on him and she's a monster
that lady did such a great job uh at
laura laura linney
she did she did a fantastic job as being
just a terrible character and she did
such a great job shout out to her
um you know so his wife so he's in this
disjointed relationship he's also a
money launderer and he's trying to be
like a good guy but he's not he makes
bad choices but he's brilliant at what
he does so then his family has to move
to the ozarks in missouri to launder
money for the mexican cartel are they
going to be dead while they're in
missouri there's like a family of drug
dealers who they have their own opium
business there and then so so now
there's a there's a fight between the
mexican cartel him uh
laundering money and then the locals you
know and then one of the locals uh the
girl that plays ruth i think that's
sofia
sophie wait they mean get their names
right who plays ruth
uh
what's her name
um
what's her name that plays she was also
in that
raise what uh i don't know what her damn
name is how come i can't see the cat
wait i'm looking i'm on imdb and it's
not showing me the cast right you know
what i mean
oh yeah yeah no no that's not her that's
the dog the girl who played the daughter
why is she like
listed as like high on the bill
like what are you talking about that
girl was just okay let's see what is the
girl's name
who plays ruth
guys
i can't they're not showing her
they're not showing her picture right
here oh here we go here we go here we go
here we go
here we go is it julie oh yeah julie
garner
julie gardner oh man i love her she's so
good like let me go to the so you can
see let me go to the screen capture part
yeah this chick right here julie garner
she was also in that movie that that
other netflix show
um inventing anna which she was great is
just like you know
i think i reviewed that show too but
anyway you know so he also meets ruth
you know and she's like this like
country bumpkin girl but she's brilliant
you know what i mean she's like a bru
she's like a a career criminal you know
she comes from a criminal family and
she's a but she's got upside it and
jason bateman's character sees it he
knows that she could be more than what
she is and he takes her under her wing
and they have this really nice sort of
like father-daughter relationship
throughout the series and it gets
contentious and
you know it's it's a really great like
that's a really great relationship you
know what i mean
so
i really enjoyed it so in the final
season spoiler spoilers okay i'm telling
you right now it's spoilers in the final
season the the the this family jason
bateman and his wife they're just oh
they're just so bad with each other and
they're bad with everyone they're really
terrible people it really just comes out
that they're not good people and they're
not good parents you know the son
becomes a money launderer himself he
starts working for ruth and the other
drug dealer lady
you know so the son is like this like
upstart little 15 year old that needed
to get his ass beat right they should
have whooped him
and then the daughter who's trying to be
a pleaser she's trying to please the mom
and the dad and you know but even she is
like about to be 18 so she'll have her
own life and and even she's a little bit
of a monster too like they're they've
infected their children with this you
know what i mean and they're showing
that and so the first part of the season
is like you know ruth trying to get from
underneath them and do her own thing and
then her cousin who's like in this weird
he's like this young boy who's like in
this relationship with this older woman
who's like this big time drug lord she
owns all this property in the ozarks and
but she's like running the opium
business there and they have this weird
relationship and they get married but
then somebody in the mexican cartel this
new guy in the cartel kills them and
that was oh my god it was such a
cliffhanger of the first half of the
season and so now ruth is out for
revenge and she gets her revenge she
kills this drug lord right but the drug
lord's mom is the sister of the main
drug lord who's in prison you know and
then and then uh you know jason bateman
and his wife are working with
he plays marty you know marty bird so
the birds are working with this drug
leader that's in prison and you know
it's this whole thing and the fbi is
involved it's like really intricate
story and all the characters but anyways
i just want to get to the end okay
i just want to get to the end and this
is a spoiler so like i said i've said it
like eight times so if you don't want to
watch please stop watching now so you
don't get the spoiler of this i love how
this
this ended this was a great season
finale to me
and i'm gonna tell you why it's hard to
do a good like when you have characters
that you really like like sopranos that
was a weird ending but you had to end it
that way game of thrones they didn't end
that great i thought that was a terrible
final season but sometimes it's hard to
end a series so
this is leading up to the birds are
trying to get out from underneath the
fbi and the drug cartel they just want
to be free so they're starting this
foundation so they can get into politics
and have their own power and money and
they've been conniving and scheming with
politicians throughout this whole thing
at the same time trying to work with the
the colombian drug lords and you know
with the they have this casino with
their laundering money
ruth swoops in and she because because
her cousin was married to the drug lord
lady
and he both they both died and he was
married to her ruth inherited everything
plus a controlling interest in the
casino so she made her play to like
legitimize herself and i loved it i was
like ruth did it okay but in the end
ruth's the one that shot the drug lord
so the sister of the drug lord and the
mother of the one she shot
she finally figures out that it was ruth
to the final episode
and it was great they're at this party
the birds have finally they finally
found a way to win
they finally found a way to get from
underneath this their foundation is
gonna they're gonna they're gonna make
them power players in the in in politics
and they're gonna be like the kennedys
and they've finally done it they've got
from underneath the fbi and everything
and then the the the the the drug lord
lady she comes over and you know she's
like you know she their business partner
the one you know the one that owns this
pharmaceutical company that like needed
the heroin for their whatever right
she cracks because the drug lord lady
was like i'm gonna if you don't tell me
the truth that what happened to my son
so she cracks because she was there and
she's like ruth did it it was ruth
you know
and then like the drug lord ladies she
like and marty cares about ruth you
could tell
marty cares about ruth
and the drug lord lady says
to her like henchmen you watch these two
if they warn her
i want you to kill the kids she go see
those kids over there that's their kids
if these two even make a move towards
warning her
kill him that's what she was implied
so now they're sitting here and they're
looking at each other like what are we
gonna do
like they care about ruth the wife not
so much but i know marty cares about
ruth
man
and then left the [ __ ] drug lord lady
goes to see ruth
and ruth is a bad [ __ ] you know what i
mean and she's standing there and she's
like oh how'd you find out you know and
little drug lord lady tells her it was i
was claire shaw you know
and then ruth is looking at ruth just
stands there and she's like you know
what
i don't regret it
because your son was a murdering [ __ ]
and now i see where he got it from she
went out like a g
and then it [ __ ]
shoots her
and then now you got the birds back at
their place and they're just like
they won
but at what what cost man at what cost
in my mind i was like they can't get
away
i hate when people like that get away
they don't deserve it
so another side story is there's this
cop
that became a detective
and he was a cop but he like he had a
drug problem he stole some cocaine so he
had to become like a private detective
and he's been on the case trying to find
their brother
trying to find the brother of the wife
and the brother was killed by the drug
cartel because of her
he was bipolar and he was gonna like get
him all killed and she made the choice
to give up her brother for her family so
they had the ashes of the brother
in a
vase the cop guy figures it out
so
now ruth is dead they're back at their
house they've won
and they're sitting there and the cops
there now he's a cop again because they
actually got his job back
to get rid of him because he was close
to messing up their thing right so now
he's got the vase and he knows the
brothers the remains are in here he
knows it
and he's like
he's like
y'all can't win
and they're like we'll give you money
we'll give you anything you want and
he's like i don't want the money he goes
he just goes people like you can't win
and then the next scene is like the sun
the 15 year old son
he comes out with a shotgun and he's
pointing at the guy
and the parents are looking at the guy
and they both look at their son like
yeah
fade to black
shotgun
and i was like
wow
like these horrible people
their son is now a murderer
like the sun knew the sun's like well we
got to kill this [ __ ] because
we we got to win
the mom finally made amends with the
kids admitted that she's a monster i'm
sorry i tried to control you
but your your uncle is dead because of
me you know
like oh man another bad oh man the
father who is terrible her father who is
a terrible guy which is probably why
she's terrible
ruth once again steps in because marty
marty bribed her marty's like look if
you don't get my kids to not leave with
her because their father was trying to
take the kids but he didn't really want
the kids he just wanted to hurt his
daughter and then ruth comes in with a
gun to the hotel room and she's like
she first of all she tricks him you know
she brings drinks and then she gets him
to admit that he's he don't care about
these kids you know and then she pulls a
gun out she was like i want you to admit
that to the kids
and then she shoots the gun and she's
like i'm gonna blow your dick off if you
don't tell these kids the truth so the
kids now
go see the mom
who checked herself into an insane
asylum because she was going to lose her
kids
and then she comes clean with the kids
and they go all right mom they don't say
that but it's like a thing where they go
you know what mom we're with you
you know they turned we're with you
man
it was just
a spectacular ending to the series i
like the psychology of it this is just
my opinion tell me in the comments if
you agree or disagree
sorry if you got spoiled but i told you
from the beginning it's in the title
spoilers
i loved it i thought ozarks was a great
series i'm glad netflix let it go four
seasons
i love i just i love getting invested in
characters and it was uh actually a well
done it was so well done
oh
man and i can't believe that in that
universe that the birds got away with it
so i almost want to see like a sequel to
the series it's like five years later
like the kids are older and they're just
totally messed up or whatever like you
know what i mean like who knows what
happens to the drug industry like does
marty go and run the cartel with the do
you know what happens it's like oh man
it was so good but anyways
i appreciate you guys
i totally appreciate you guys for uh
being here you know um
where's my where's my where's my thing
there we go let me turn this off
you know um
thanks for being here as always
um
just another
you know episode of
with griffin so you know make sure you
subscribe
share
all that stuff check out my dates um um
i'm actually coming to
where am i coming let's uh let's go up
let's let's pull up the website that i
still need to like fix and work on you
know what i mean it is what it is
but yes uh i am
i'm coming to so may 21st if you're in
the la area i'm going to be with creed
bratton from the office we're doing like
he's doing like some music i'm doing
comedy at the mint on pico
uh the arlington improv in dallas
arlington improv in dallas may 26th
through the 29th come check me out there
arlington and then comedy off broadway
lexington kentucky june 2nd to the 4th
come check me out there if you want to
watch me live i really enjoy doing
comedy so
i really appreciate you guys watching
the show being here sharing subscribing
make sure you check me out on twitch i'm
on twitch daily
eric griffin gaming so come check me out
there also put the videos up on youtube
eric griffin gaming so once again thanks
for being here see you next week
me
[Music]
you